donc toi tu dit olivier alors tu prends
ta femme tu prends l'ascenseur ce mardi
matin à guyancourt on se distribuent les
répliques et faut que amos et une sève à
sa disposition
ça va être toi ouais et les rôles tous
sont en recherche d'emploi ils
participent à ce stage pour une reprise
de confiance en soi
en fait moi je suis justement comédien
actuellement j'ai fait j'étais un petit
peu un petit peu sortis du circuit
donc je vais voir les services sociaux
du coup leurs yeux sont allumés quand
j'ai dit bon comédien m'a envoyé ici
le but c'est pas qu'on soit des
professionnels c'est vraiment on prend
tant qu'amateur et entendre que personne
qui vont juste s'amuser juste montrer un
peu ce qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent valoir
deux semaines de préparation durant
lesquelles ils ont écrit leurs propres
textes et monter une pièce de 15 minutes
le thème était tout trouvé le travail
alors prenez l'apport est maintenant au
travail
ils sont dirigés par le metteur en scène
françois chaffin en résidence à la ferme
de bel ébat ses douze stagiaires
monteront sur scène en avant première de
sa pièce
c'est une manière aussi de dédramatiser
de prendre un peu de distance par
rapport à un quotidien ces solitaires de
recherche d'emploi le grand jour est
arrivé dernier moment de stress en
coulisses moi j'ai peur j'ai peur
d'avoir des trous j'ai peur de pas
savoir comment m'y prendre
j'espère que les gens peu
ag par quoi avant des pâtes et des
spectateurs sous les projecteurs moi ce
stage issue d'un partenariat entre la
ville et la ferme de bel ébat existe
depuis 2012 une aventure que les élus en
charge de l'emploi et de la culture ne
sont pas prêtes à abandonner garantir le
la prise en compte pour les demandeurs
d'emploi de même aussi bien dans leur
corps que dans leur expression c'est
très important
les artistes qui sont en résidence ici
on cette mission aussi d'aller chercher
les publics
un vrai groupe qui s'est formé désormais
prêt à affronter cette recherche
d'emploi bien entouré et mon confiance
non